I am Ernestine shepherd 80 years of age
[Music]
ident
press 110 pound I started training at
age 71 I was named the oldest female
competitive bodybuilder and the Guinness
Book of World Records my sister and I
started exercising together I had never
done any type of exercising before
before she died she said promise me you
will follow my dream and try to get in
the Guinness Book of World Records so
that's what I did
I have been in six or seven competitions
I win but some I come out second and
third and I'm pleased with that
I'm up every morning at 2:30 after I
have my devotion I walk and I write
approximately 10 miles I'm at the gym at
7:30 and I have a group of ladies that I
train down I train all ages one of the
youngest I pitch is about 20 years of
age and the rest go from 14 all the way
up till 80 when people come to my class
for the very first time they are really
really surprised they said I didn't
think this exercise would be this tough
but you can do it we are going to do it
too
I really don't feel as though I'm 80
years of age but I am I want to keep
training until my day is
[Music]